what we have depicted here is an economy
in long-run equilibrium notice the point
at which the aggregate demand curve and
the short-run aggregate supply curve
intersect that specifies an equilibrium
price level pl sub 1 and an equilibrium
level of output this equilibrium level
of output y sub 1 but notice that point
of intersection it also intersects the
long run aggregate supply curve and so
that is also our full employment output
and just a reminder full employment
output does not mean that everyone in
the economy is employed it means that
this is the level of employment that is
sustainable the level of full employment
if for some reason the unemployment rate
were to get lower than that that would
be an unsustainable situation for this
economy but what we really care about in
this video is what happens if our
aggregate demand curve shifts in the
short run and in the long run so let's
just imagine there's all sorts of
positive news and aggregate demand
shifts up
so let's imagine so let me just shift
our aggregate demand curve
so
it shifts like that so all of a sudden
everyone has become more optimistic and
at a given price level they just want to
demand more output well what's going to
happen in this universe well in this
universe we have a new short run
equilibrium
so we are now right over there let's
call this
let's call this
price
level 2
and then this is output level two
so y
sub two here and so what happened well
in the short run we see that prices are
prices are going to go up the suppliers
of the output are going to say hey hey
all these people want my output now i'm
going to charge more for it and i'm also
going to increase output i was like hey
there's a bonanza going on people are
not only not only the demand anymore but
they're willing to pay for it more and
so our output actually goes beyond our
full employment output and so you can
imagine maybe unemployment goes below
the sustainable rate all sorts of people
instead of going to school or getting a
job or whatever else they're coming out
of retirement to work because there's
just a bonanza going on but what's going
to happen in the long run
well in the long run people who are
working and could say gee you know my
firm is having this bonanza
when my employment contract comes due
i'm going to ask for a raise and so as
as labor prices go up what's going to
happen to the short run aggregate supply
curve
yes it is going to shift up as well
and so let's make it shift well up as
well people are going to demand more and
more and more and more and more and more
money all the way to the point that we
get to our sustainable level of output
again
and so what really happened is at first
we had this price inflation and output
increased beyond a sustainable level and
then people say hey no no i'm i want you
know i want more for my time and so as
wages went up then prices went up even
further and so we get back to and if
prices are going up even further then
even with the shifted aggregate demand
curve people's like well i might not
want that much of it anymore and then we
shift back to this point right over here
and so now if this was aggregate demand
2 after everyone got all optimistic we
will call this short run
aggregate supply 2
and our equilibrium price now is a good
bit higher price level three but we are
back to our full employment output so we
could call this y sub three which is the
same thing as y sub one
which is equal to our full employment
output and what you have just seen this
is known as the long-run self-adjustment
mechanism it's an argument that
economists will sometimes make using
this simplified model to say hey if
you're in a situation that's either
above your full employment output or
below your full employment output it's
okay it will in the long run self-adjust
government might not have to intervene
in future videos or in other videos
we'll talk about how a government might
want to intervene in either direction
but this is an argument that's saying
well look then in the short run things
might deviate from your full employment
output but in the long run they're going
to there's natural mechanisms that will
allow output to get back to your natural
potential your full employment output